good morning John let's go to the
warehouse to get my pizza Miss stuff
the team at dftba has been working their
butts off for months getting ready for
this I cannot believe they've pulled
some of these things off when a pizza
John Chia Pet was proposed to me I said
that's a fun idea y'all but we're not
gonna be able to make it happen and yet
it is a very pretty day in Missoula
Montana if they could all be like this
everybody would live here
let's get it
[Applause]
[Music]
and now I've got my box it's just a lot
of enthusiasm for pizza John John it
never it does not decrease now I have
pizza John stuff it's time to go home
and give myself a mustache going bald
and then having your hair grow back and
suddenly getting facial hair and seeing
my my face in the mirror in a bunch of
different ways like I'm a totally
different person I saw it coming on Tick
Tock that said and green went from uh
from enthusiastic ta to grizzled tenured
professor at two months and yeah I feel
that it's just made me very confident in
a way that like I'm not I don't have to
be like away I looked one way so long
I've had some looks over the years some
of them I don't feel great about I bet
why'd I mix it up I had a mohawk for a
little while and now I'm gonna have a
mustache how is that gonna go there's no
way to know I can't believe I'm saying
goodbye to my first beard
not go TV this is what goatee Hank looks
like now ah I think it looks fine who is
that guy who's that guy
that's a different guy if you're gonna
walk through a white over here I think I
may be the one who knocks
I suppose that's a look it's a look that
some people could have I'm excited to
not have it honestly there was so much
hair
[Music]
I feel like we found ourselves at sort
of the Classic Pizza John here uh where
the mustache keeps going down for a
little while just for like Peak
Ridiculousness but I think I'm gonna
clean mine up I think that's yours John
but what's mine
[Music]
good
yeah I mean there's a look
oh yeah one two three
[Music]
[Applause]
one two three
[Music]
[Applause]
one two three
Happy Pizza Miss John from whoever the
heck this guy is I'm looking at him
right now
I don't know he's that guy he's me
what's me John I'll see you tomorrow
foreign
[Music]